welcome to this video playing em western
em western give me come on my mouth yeah
there's no name in there I've played him
quite a bit three out of eight it's not
a good score okay he's giving me a pawn
down the bank or gambit yeah it is
playing this new line where why does
some allowed the movie form ah really
have forgotten this only checked it
briefly once I am this is this line has
become a bit popular former Black simply
due to the fact that the the regular
main line is under under huge pressure
was this plate and have no idea actually
now taking Queenie to I think but yeah
not a huge fan of an endgame in the bank
o Queen 86 of course iam okay I'm still
AM okay okay place e 6 down okay let's
take it take that and trying to claim
that this is not a full compensation not
sure if I can do this again can raise
that claim successfully he has some
active pieces for sure the night's
especially okay so how do I go about
that maybe Ruby em
you know this is not easy to play black
has definite compensation here b3
doesn't look very nice I want to play
that night c 2 is always always in there
Bishop f4 Bishop f4 I could have played
that much quicker it's not so clear
where his bishop is going and I might
have Bishop b5 Bishop b5 is a good okay
nighty knight c6 then rookie to he will
play d5 it's not at all easy to play
this position I'm not really sure maybe
I mean that very very likely as he has
full compensation if not it is some it
is definitely not easy to play this
that's quite often one problem in any
banco type of sacrifice scenario you
sometimes really have the better
position for as Wyatt but it's not at
all easy to play absolutely not yeah boo
this interesting pawn takes is more
aggressive though okay I was wondering
maybe Bishop to e5 or e3 simply a three
and then defies the prior I'm not
threatening to take the night that is a
problem here and he has d4 in them in
the position B 390 form they're not not
not comfortable can I go here d4 Knight
B 594 now you can just take the b5 not
terrible my background is weak on top of
everything I came let's do this as was
one of the moves I had seen earlier but
I thought I might have something better
my bank robbed I mean not my main
problem the position has also tricky but
i'm also down on time spending tons of
time d for Bishop f6 Bishop F 694 that
was my IDM dc-3 bishops III should
should be fine hmm that should be fine
Bishop takes Knight if okay he goes for
that quite surprising I mean the best
that I see is that he gets a to back
which doesn't seem like a completely
satisfactory solution TX takes my real
killers hangs but I can go look be one
area also what is this rookie 196 I
cannot take
rook be 196 but it keeps a porn at least
right it keeps a poem knight c6 I can go
look see one I'm terribly slow the I
don't think the moves are that bad but
I'm really slow okay I couldn't take
twice that because of the maid I should
really say that my background is weak
but yeah I think he has to what that is
if that is worse though that's a worse
solution I think ok be 5c 4b six I'm
quicker here right so b 6i can also get
the King up now we're pushing for king
bee three yeah King diff King up yep and
king and rugby five that's it's nice I
can also probably get the pattern here
f4 takes g4 okay it's just about time
work just about holding huh that's
unfortunate why my miscounting f 1 p-6
takes tapes g [ __ ] c6f5 take six
kindy six ok that's not enough so I have
to do this which is not ideal check
I'm a porn up though at least gym but it
should have been more I think I made
some kind of mistake in this end game oh
I didn't think about that movie at all
oh that's that could be a problem is
going here f4 is going up okay don't get
it just pushing stuff now black resigns
I was really stunned he go he went into
the king of Poland came there isn't this
lost I mean the only idea he has us go
to e2 and then f 4g four hits i mean
just losing right or not let's check
this went here can be 64 king here it
must be lost right he had his totally
lost he has only this idea i can only go
forward and then I'm just losing of
course I'm just winning of course damn
it's just a win no need to analyze their
the rook endgame is the real question he
has to go rook a6 I was thinking and
went here I thought you just has to go
there go there and defend this this is
ultimately a draw three against two I
wonder and now he's putting out those
moves um this is this is this is a draw
probably but the question question is is
earlier I'd like to like to know if if I
can do if I can take them probably not
maybe i can i wonder if i can win here
somehow it looks like i might be able to
win with the pawn this is this Chang mmm
very tricky very tricky situation I was
thinking actually that when we when we
were here okay I made a mistake there i
can check him oh god that is strong this
is strong because no and now this is
hanging with a check here b7 is hanging
with a check my mouse is still a problem
b7 SI me was checked so he cannot move
the night that would have one apiece
straight away I didn't see that one I
was glad to have spotted the the pin
there but i was thinking he's some
playing knight c6 that was I this is
what he played a thought he placed
Knight to c6 in this position but I
thought rook see one that was my idea
yeah and now I have gone rid of this
night and maybe I can let's say if he
takes which is maybe not a good idea now
I have night see for coming or not efore
coming one of one of those two ideas
with the blockade on attack tricky i was
there was a very difficult game i hope
you enjoyed it thanks for watching